in a free week  race you're always fueling for the next  day and the next week even  as much as that specific day because you  want to perform the best you can  regardless of if you're riding for  yourself or to help someone else i think  that's what you have to aim for and of  course you know  different circumstances and the race can  can change that and maybe you have to  work earlier or later  somewhere in between it's a constantly  moving target you don't know how hard  the stage is going to be but you just  try to  plan for what you do know and control  that and then have strategy in place for  how you're going to adapt to different  situations